we want to get to breaking news
overnight from Atlanta where former
President Jimmy Carter is due to have
brain surgery this morning the 39th
president has had a series of Falls this
year and doctors say that's led to
severe swelling mark Strassmann is
outside Emory University Hospital mark
good morning so what do we know about
this surgery
oh good morning the goal of today's
procedure is to relieve pressure on mr.
Carter's brain doctors say the issue is
internal bleeding after several recent
Falls it's the latest in a series of
health scares for America's old as
president just last month he turned 95
the Carter Center says former President
Jimmy Carter will undergo a surgical
brain procedure this morning something
he needs because of recent Falls mr.
Carter has fallen three times this year
in May his first fall broke his hip and
last month he fell twice the first
resulted in 14 stitches the second a
fractured pelvis CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus says the type
of procedure mr. Carter will undergo is
normally quick it involves drilling a
small hole in the brain and draining
fluid that's causing pressure mr.
Carter's time in the operating room is
expected to be about one hour hi Jimmy
Carter do solemnly swear the 39th
president has had several major medical
problems in recent years in 2015 he was
diagnosed with cancer that spread to his
liver and brain he recovered after
treatment with a new immunotherapy drug
and six months later announced he was
cancer-free what should I do personally
despite those setbacks mr. Carter has
continued his normal routine which
includes teaching Sunday school classes
in his hometown of Plains Georgia
earlier this month mr. Carter spoke to a
Sunday School class about his recent
health concerns and his own mortality
I didn't ask God to let me live out his
has God to give me proper attitude
toward death and I found that I was
absolutely and completely at ease with
death
mr. Carter also continued his work at
Habitat for Humanity last year he spoke
to our John Dickerson about the
importance of that project there are
1700 volunteers were
here what does that tell you about
America it tells me that America has a
great orientation toward helping people
in need Rosalyn Carter is with her
husband here at the hospital doctors say
he's resting comfortably they recently
became America's longest married
presidential couple 73 years longer than
George and Barbara Bush ago Anthony
congratulations to them and we wish you
a speedy recovery
yes all right mark thank you